So, we're nearing the end of the course,
and we've had a great time building this
content for you, and we hope that you've gotten a lot of value out of this.
>> So, we've run tons of meetups and workshops about Dorm Room Debbie
and building pizza applications. And, one thing that's always true is that the
developers at these events come up with the most amazing ideas for features
and applications that are context aware. Stuff that I can never even think of.
>> Yeah, and we're trying to put all of this together
into a Repository of Awesomeness. I mean, you know,
we get a couple hundred, folks come through the workshops.
>> Yep. .
>> But, through this class, we have the potential to reach thousands of people.
So, imagine all of you posting your
amazing ideas that, we haven't thought about, that
others have not thought about, in this one Repository of Awesome that can serve
as a source of inspiration for you
months from now after you've taken this class.
>> So, let's get creative. Take the most amazing ideas you
can think of, whether or not they can be implemented or
not, and go to the forum and post them under the Repository of Awesomeness.